so you're a top laner playing a tank
you're doing your thing last hitting
creeps and occasionally slapping the
other top laner with your wet noodle
Auto attack the lane is boring but
everything seems to be going well
life is good until it happens you get
ganked
ganking is the act of ruining someone's
day by grouping up with at least one
other person to ambush and kill them if
you've watched or played any competitive
MOBA in the last 10 years then you'll be
very familiar with this concept in
league the chief perpetrators of this
devious act are junglers the same sly
bastards usually behind stealing near
baron or elder dragon from out of
nowhere he's gone down is Jia is gonna
get popped bender a little bit too low
in this one is just
Hey
while jungling as a position doesn't
exist in DotA ganking is typically
executed by roaming supports for the
same purpose oh my god I thought that
was just a cute play or something but
you might be surprised to hear that
ganking didn't actually start in MOBAs
in fact it wasn't started video games at
all according the castles dictionary of
slang the word gank emerged in the 1980s
as Street talk for fake cocaine wait a
second what's that down there keep
scrolling stop gar boom one who sniffs
bicycle seats for sexual excitement
you're so funny
anyway as the years went on gank became
a general term for ripping someone off
weather was from selling them fake drugs
or straight-up robbing them in the 90s
Genki was referenced in the music of
some of the era's most iconic rappers
like easy
[Music]
oddly by 1997 the term had somehow found
its way from street hardened gangsta rap
to probably the last thing you'd
associate with hip-hop culture ultima
online this Britannia is but one of many
in the mold
Ultima Online
Ultima Online was one of the first
hugely popular mmo's and its death
penalty system which allowed players to
loot each other's corpses paved the way
for gang to enter gamers vocabularies
indubitably it turns out that Ultima
Online was actually gangster as [__]
he gave what you gave was gay gay gay
and as griefing became more and more
popular in MMO culture ganking quickly
transformed from online muggings into a
specific term for ganging up with some
friends and beating down lower level
players kill me one more time see what
happens
okay a few moments later alright I'll
bring my other rope where are you are
you [__]
Jib [__] baited [__] jebaited who's
your daddy
you're gonna gank me I think not
eventually ganking found its way into
dota where it took on the meaning we
associated with today she would watch
[Music]
but despite the fact the etymology of
gank is pretty clear some people have
come up with their own [__] origins
for the word perhaps the most believed
fable is that it's short for gang kill
which in terms of abbreviated word
construction doesn't really add up I
mean wouldn't it make more sense for the
word gang to be a combination of gang
and flank others have suggested that
gank is an acronym but we didn't find
any convincing examples of what it could
actually stand for for all we know it
could be group ambush neutralized kill
or maybe even gritty adores North Korea
hate is cuz they anus they hate does it
because they ain't us today ganking is
most commonly tied to the MOBA genre and
since the earliest days of dota and
League it has been a very popular and
effective tactic ganks can be completely
momentum shifting events during a match
and usually lead to early advantages
that are capable of turning into
significant leads and sure while it
really sucks being wedgied for your
lunch money in lane as a spectator
watching a tightly executed gang can be
a thing of absolute beauty just get back
up eventually though because with that
play top lane date
blushes the baby cage scorer in Terrenas
x5 don't for the beats like solo shows
restaurant assadís Stampede right
through him FY he's absolutely go
comes back in the action here gets it
done and said see you later
take your sniper kill and
away separates the fight it up for mm to
throw at the calling Herod the flash
Tonto play from under the wall the tribe
revolt but not old gangster is clean and
calculated as those and sometimes
watching the sloppy ones backfire can be
equally as enjoyable it looks like good
we're gonna see a little bit of gank
attempt on the middling and Noah blasts
oh here it comes no alas the cars gonna
be on top zài they'll taking a little
bit of damage and we try to group with
disillusions the right click two seconds
a lot of damage coming in translations
gonna also stay alive but now Sven is on
the chase but most burn the flash
beneath the Wanaka the coupler autos
come through the watchword is attacking
and spin scarran kills himself in the
top plane and fnatic is not done
jumping Florida's camps he's got the
chain as well I cannot believe that
actually I actually cannot believe that
too much people he's looking for the
brain sappers and there you have it
everything you need to know about how to
be a master ganker but if you have any
questions about how to be a master a
wanker I'm sure Matt can help you on
that one
just kidding that alright I'm not here
dude
[Music]
haha very funny guys
brings back Josh guys I'm just fooling
in you'll be back I swear
so you're a top laner plain tank you're
doing the thing last hitting creeps and
occasional slapping the other top laner
with your wet noodle or to attack